Hi, everybody.
Happy New Year. If I
haven't said it yet to you,
and then welcome back to the
data science hangout. I'm
Rachel. I lead customer
marketing at Posit.
I'm excited to be back
here with you all.
This is our first hangout
of twenty twenty four.
The hangout is our open space
to hear what's going on in the
world of data across
different industries,
chat about data
science leadership,
and connect with others facing
similar things as you. We get
together here every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So if this is your
first time joining us,
it is so nice to meet
you. Is it anybody's first hangout?
Say hi in the chat because we'd
love to welcome you in and say
hello to anybody joining
for the first time too.
We're all dedicated to keeping
this a friendly and welcoming
space for everyone.
So we love hearing from
you no matter your years of
experience, titles, industry,
or languages that you work in.
It's also totally okay if you
just wanna listen in here and
awesome to be a part of the
party that happens in the Zoom chat too.
But there's also three ways you
can jump in and ask questions
today or provide your own
perspective on certain topics too.
So
if you've been here before,
you've heard this whole spiel
before, but the three ways to,
jump in are you can raise your
hand on zoom and I'll call on
you. You could put
questions in the Zoom chat,
and feel free to just put a
little star next to it if it's
something you want me to
read out loud instead.
And then we also have a
slido link where you can ask
questions anonymously,
and our team will share that in
the chat here in just a second.
A quick note that if you
are watching the recording at some
point in the future on YouTube
and wanna join us live,
The link to add it to your
calendar will be in the details
below to join us.
And there's no rule that you
have to say the whole time or
talk and you can come and
go. As it fits your schedule.
Well, with all that, welcome.
I am so excited to be
joined by my cohost for today, Mayran,
AI and ML Accelerator and
enablement at TD Bank Group.
And, Mary, I would love to
have you introduce yourself to and
share a little bit about
your role and also something you
like to do outside of work.
And you can also educate us
on how to pronounce your last name
as well because I know we didn't
get to that in the first part.
Yeah. No worries. Yeah. So
it's, the proper way is,
but, you know, I've been in
Canada since I was, like, six.
And I think I I
accept many different pronunciations. So,
you know, that's not a problem.
Thank you.
So, yeah, so, super
happy to be here and,
hopefully get chat
with some of you folks.
Yeah, so I've been at, TD
Bank group for a while now,
so it's coming
close to ten years.
So I started as an intern
there, actually, and,
my background is
actually actual mathematics. So,
I got there and, you know,
wanna be like a very good
actuary. Do all my
exams and everything,
but since then I kinda deviated
quite a bit, I would say.
So I had some non
traditional roles there,
some innovation teams,
and then sort of like looped
back into sort of more of the
data science world. And, now I
lead, like, a small team of,
Sort of it's fairly, I
would say diverse. There's some,
actuaries in there. There's some
more ML engineers and, ML scientists
and the goal is sort
of to, you know,
get these sort of use cases,
started on across the line
where in some industries, you
know, there are
more challenges and,
we can I'm sure we're gonna
be talking about some of those.
On my sort of, like,
free time, actually, this holiday season.
I got really into, like,
home automation stuff. So, you know,
I I'm I'm a lazy person,
but I'm also the type of
person that will spend, like, you know,
ten hours to automate something
that probably takes like,
you know, a few minutes
of, like, manual work.
So it's a bit of a,
you know, counterintuitive thing. So so,
yeah, Son, I have a friend
who is very into privacy.
Those two things don't
go well together.
So home automation and
privacy. Typically,
you have to subscribe to
a bunch of cloud services.
So I got into this thing
called home assistant.
You have your own server. So it
kinda took a lot of my time.
So that's, you know, if you wanna
talk to me about, like, you know,
home automation and server
management and things like
that, you know, feel free.
That's sort of like
what I'm into right now.
But yeah.
I need to know what one of
those home automations is then.
Okay. So, so I
live in Montreal,
so in Canada, so it gets pretty
cold. And my house, I have,
like, a home humidifier,
like a whole home humidifier.
But the thing is, you know,
when the temperature drops
below certain amount and if you
set your humidity
levels too high,
your windows start
getting foggy.
So mine is like manual. I have
to go down in my basement.
I'm like manually adjust it
so that it doesn't get foggy.
So this whole
setup I have, like,
humidity sensors and with
the external temperature sensors so
that it automatically adjusts so that
I don't have to do this
manually. So that's that's
It sounds straightforward,
but that that sort of
thing actually took a decent amount
of my time to to set up. But
it was it was cool. It was fun.
Awesome. I love hearing
about everybody's side projects here.
Well, Mary,
to while I wait for questions
to come in from everybody here,
I thought To get us started,
could you share an example of
maybe a data project or a use
case that your team has worked on?
I think that's always it
always helps us kind of better
understand your day to
day work and challenges.
Yeah. For sure.
So there's some particularly
interesting use cases that we
we've worked on. And
typically, you know,
our use cases always
start from, let's say,
a problem statement.
Right? So so we try to
position ourselves as,
not being sort of like a,
you know, our only tool is,
let's say, a model and
that's what we're gonna deliver to
you. You know, we
look at the problem.
We've really tried to
discuss it with the business,
what what they need,
and sometimes, you know,
the answer might be, you know,
you need to talk to a vendor.
Right? Like, this isn't
something we wanna do
internally, and sometimes
it turns out that, okay,
this is something that we
we wanna do internally.
Of the use cases that
was particularly really interesting was,
you know, this is,
before COVID times and then
during COVID times where our
call center started getting,
some operational issues.
And when COVID happened,
things just started getting
worse and worse. And, you know,
a lot of folks try to come
up with solutions and and
approaches to kind of solving
some of these problems,
but what we really realize
very quickly is that,
we don't have the proper,
you know,
dataset curated to actually
even understand what the
problem is, right, like, and
then try to give solutions.
So that was that was
a huge amount of work.
And initially, it
started out as a, like,
billing a curated data set,
but then it evolved into, actually,
like, a full fledged coaching
application for our call
centers. And this is something
that is ongoing today,
and it's used quite a bit
where we give, you know,
not just metrics and things,
but actually we tell the
managers, like, this is specifically
what you need to look at.
And this is what this specific
person needs to be coached on.
So just being able to
give those insights directly to
people and, you know, there's a
front end to it and, you know,
pause that has been
like extremely helpful in that,
but the amount of like
data and, you know,
sort of like models and things
that go behind that beef and
it's all transparent
to the end user,
but That's one of the really cool
projects that we got to work on.
That's an awesome use case.
Thank you for sharing that.
So what it what does the front
end look like for them or what
what is the front end?
Yeah. And that's the other
thing. So one of the other
things that we were able to
do, and this is sort of, like,
part of the accelerator mindset in
our team, I guess, is that,
you know, we work really
in MVP. So, you know, agile
is the, you know,
flavor of the month or at least
it's been the flavor of the
month for for a while now. But,
like, we really kind of, like, you know,
take that to heart in the
sense that when it started off,
the UI
was fairly straightforward.
It was a sort of like
a shiny application
It gave some
insights, some things.
But I would say we did, like,
feature releases on a on a
monthly basis. And even earlier
on, it was even faster.
I was sorry with a pilot
program where we had, you know,
a group of advisors and it
kinda, like, grew and became,
became fairly large to the
point that, you know, it was
all of, the the insurance
business covered under this.
So it started as a shiny
application, then, you know,
we realized that
It's great. Things are good,
but if you want to sort of
like scale it out, like, even further,
not that it can't be done
with shiny and you you can
definitely, you know, do things
modules and things like that.
We had the resources available to
us to kinda take it a step
further and, like,
create like a proper back end
set of APIs and create like
content and like,
JavaScript, with VJAS,
and that that's how
the application is today.
And it's still evolving.
We could still, you know,
there's monthly feature edition with
the feedback from the business,
but it's sort of like agile way
that's sort of the I would say
the main benefit of
something like this.
Thank you.
I know when we were talking
before, I guess, it's kinda
this continues on this topic,
but on our pre call,
you talked about, like,
the speed of reaction
to business needs.
And I was just wondering,
how has the emphasis on the
ways you interact with business
users and that speed of
reaction contributed to your team's success.
And you can speak in terms
of that use case specifically or
or a different one too.
Yeah. I would say that is
the main sort of ingredient of success.
Because at the end of the day
so there's there's maybe two two elements,
but that one is very important
because at the end of the day,
you know, a lot of times and,
you know, business users,
but just typically as a person,
when you think of, you know,
oh, this is something that
I want. You might say it,
but then when it
gets into your hands,
you realize, okay, like, this
is what I said, but actually,
and now I realize what I
wanted is something different.
And there's two approaches to
this. One of the approach is,
you know, you sit down, you
do a lot of, like, you know,
workshops and you
try to create, like,
a proper requirements document.
And that's, you know, for
certain use that are very, like,
high risk and you need to make
sure you get it right on the
first try, that is appropriate.
But for a lot of uses,
it's better to just, you know,
give the user something so that
they can use it and give you
feedback. And then based
off of that feedback, again,
you have to kinda, you
know, take it and understand, okay,
they're giving this feedback,
what does it exactly mean
and give them something that kind
of addresses that.
Being able to do
that very quickly,
that is a huge element of the
of the success here. Because after a while,
we started having this
relationship with a business
where they knew that, you know,
what we gave them, if it wasn't
perfect, they could
come back to us,
and we would take it
a step further. Right?
And having that sort of like
trust that's what kind of
enables a lot of these projects
to kinda get off the ground.
Thank you. Alan, I see see
you have question in the chat.
You wanna ask that here?
Yeah. Sure. Hi, Mad.
I'm really curious.
I've seen tension in
the past with, like,
accelerator or innovation teams
making really cool things and
then running into problems of,
like, how do those get
supported long term? Because, like,
these little innovation teams
usually aren't resource to to
handle that. Do you run into
that kind of tension and how
have you figured
out how to, like,
make things that are
sustainable and know when to
hand them off and know that
you've got partners who can take them.
Any good solutions in that
kind of organizational area?
Yeah, for sure. So this is
this is a very important point.
And I think that's been
one of the biggest challenges that
we've solved sort
of incrementally.
So
one of the most important
things is even before starting
a use case like this,
and I think, you know,
it requires a certain level
of maturity that I would say,
like, early on in our
journey we maybe didn't have,
but we were kinda lucky in certain
ways is You need to be very,
direct with the business
and make them understand that,
like, look, we can build this.
We can build this very quickly.
And it's fun to do to
build, but it will require maintenance.
And maintenance means there
is cost associated to that.
So we need to make sure
that whatever they're asking for has
benefits, right,
like actual tangible benefits so that
when we do go back to
them and say, like,
look, I to, you know,
assign like an FTE to kinda
do long term support for this.
They're okay with
funding. Right?
So that part is very
important. And, you know,
we need to be very direct
about that very upfront, right?
Which is why a lot of the
use cases that we we tend to
support their
fairly high value.
And when they're
very high value,
you go back to them and
you're like, look, I can build this.
It'll cost you next to nothing.
For support, we need to
kind of support this,
and that will kinda have
some costs. Typically,
they're they're
they're okay with that.
So that's one part of it.
The other part of it is,
you know, making things
sort of standardized.
And when I say standardized, I
don't necessarily mean that, you know,
make like a cookie cutter
application that kinda applies
everywhere, but have these
sort of, like, frameworks that,
you know, you customize
that, you know,
if you take somebody
that doesn't have experience in
this, but he's worked on
a similar application,
he can come and he can support
as well. So by doing that,
we're able to have like a
fairly small group of tea a
fairly small group of people that
can be the sort of ongoing
support team as well as
the development team.
So that's that's
part of the equation.
Then there's a another part of
the equation is that, you know,
you start kinda looking like an
IT team once you start building
all these layers, and
we're not an IT team.
Right?
So then you need to have a
proper relationship with your
IT team. Team and kind of,
you know, set the limits of, like,
okay. Well, the infrastructure you
own, you own sort of, like,
let's say even the deployment
of the applications, but, like,
the l l to support, like,
if there's something wrong
with the application and stuff,
then that's what we own.
So making sure that you
have these operating models that
kinda make this work,
that's sort of like the magic
recipe because if it all on
the, let's say, the
analytics team side.
That's not really gonna be
sustainable and work long term.
And if it's all on
the IT side, know,
we've seen that that
doesn't work either.
So having this collaboration
is really the key.
Nice. Yeah. A lot of
that sounds familiar.
We're we're still trying
to figure out organization with
how to solve some
of things, get,
get support for the things that
we wanna live in IT versus not,
and, and it's tricky.
So, it's very tricky.
It's great to hear you've
got a successful model.
It's really cool. Thanks.
How did you set up
those different levels
for, like, who handles
which applications or what
what is considered IT?
Yeah. That's a good
question. And, you know,
it's a it's a tricky one.
And I feel like our
story is probably not that different
from a lot of other other
people. So, you know,
initially this kind of started
off as something that's like,
you know, kind of, you
know, back of the envelope,
and then we got
something handed to the business.
And it kind of, like, started
growing incrementally.
We had the necessary resources
to make sure that from the
business's perspective, we
were able to support them. So
And and the fact is
because these applications kind of
always get new features
and get everything,
they're never really in
maintenance mode it's not like,
oh, it's set and we just
need somebody to, like,
make sure it runs. They're
always in development kind of.
Right? So because of that,
we always had the had the
resources to kind of support
this and the business, you
know, from their perspective,
they were supportive. So
they were super happy.
We got to a point where
then the enterprise was like, okay.
You guys are doing things
that are, like, very operational.
And you're kind of doing things
that, like, IT should be doing.
And when we got to that
point, it was like, yes.
We kind of agree with but
we had already made the business
case that there's value in
doing this this way because I
would say before we even
got there, the discussions were
like, well, no, this Like,
you guys shouldn't be coding.
It should be IT
that does it. Right?
But once the value was there
and once the business was like,
wait, I like what
these guys are doing,
the discussion kinda changed and
it became more like, okay.
Well, you know,
you have the analytics team that
is building these things, but like,
how do we put all the right
controls on everything in place
to make this something that
is sustainable and is within the
risk profiles that, let's say, a
bank like TD kind of accept.
Right? And that is
really, you know,
you need to bring in
a lot of partners.
It's a lot of discussions,
and I would say these
discussions kinda take, like, years.
Right? It's not something that
gets solved, like, you know,
in a single meeting,
there's a lot of back and forth
until you kind of find this
middle ground of an operating
model where you keep your agility,
but you're able to have all
the right controls in place to make
sure that, you know,
everybody's kinda, you know,
feel safe and happy.
So would you recommend building
something impactful for the
business first before
thinking? Too much about, like,
who handles what?
Or
So, I mean, it it depends on
your industry, and it depends on how
conservative your industry is.
Right? So the
banking industry in Canada
especially. Right? Like Canada,
yeah, like, six
banks, and that's it.
So it's it's very conservative.
So the risk of doing something
at hurting the bank are almost
always higher than the risk
of not doing anything at all.
Right? So in that
kind of an industry,
you have to be very careful.
And and the truth is, like,
you know, we do handle a
lot of their of information.
We do have to be very
careful with these things. Right? Like,
that is priority number one
whenever we're doing any project.
So in these kind of industries,
having something that is tangible
that you can get, like,
a small group of users to use
it and see the benefits goes a
long way. Now
how far do you want to
take it before, you know,
you want to have
those conversations?
That kind of depends
on, you know,
how risky that application
or whatever your building is.
Right? Like, if it's
something that requires, like,
really high risk data,
it's very operational,
then might wanna have
those conversations very early on,
but if if it's things that,
you know, they're very low impact,
let's say the business can live
it without if it goes down for,
like, two weeks,
then, you know,
you have a little
bit more freedom.
But you you do need to
build that trust with the business
and the business
does need to see,
like, something tangible
that they can, like,
kind of understand and touch
because that's when the value
becomes kinda, like, real time.
Thank
you.
I know,
some people join right after
the beginning where I give the
whole spiel about how
you can ask questions.
So I wanna remind everybody
that you can just raise your
hand here on zoom, and
I'll kinda keep an eye out.
If you wanna jump in, you
can put questions into the zoom
chat And if it's something you
wanted me to read out loud,
just put another put
a star next to it too.
Maybe you're in a coffee
shop or something.
And then we do have
the slide link.
I just re posted in the chat
where you can ask things
anonymously too.
I realize if I say that
in the first minute,
some people may
have missed that.
But, Miran, I
I'm curious if you can, like,
share a little bit with us about
some of tools that your team uses,
or maybe some
insights into, like,
key tools and technologies that
play a significant role in your
in your workflows.
Yeah. For sure. So,
so we are actually mid
migration. So currently are
our main analytics platform
is a hadoop enterprise platform
like self hosted on premise.
So we have tools like Spark.
Spark is sort of like the
main go to hive for, like, data,
ETFs and things like that.
That's sort of like on
the infrastructure side.
More on the,
sort of on the data scientist
side. So we do we do use
a positive workbench
quite a bit on prem.
Our insurance business in
particular uses Posit Workbench.
The rest of the bank tends
to use JupyterLab quite a bit.
We have sort a containerized
SuperLabLab environment,
and we have POS Connect, which
is where all these sort of,
like, applications on front
ends kind of end up living. Is,
is positive connect.
Now moving on to Azure.
So we're making a big migration
They're we're very
Databricks centric,
at the moment.
We're looking into other tools
like Azure and things like
that, but Today, it's
very Databricks Century.
So it's there's a whole
stack of of tools there,
but Databricks being the main,
sort of, you know,
analytics engine environment. So,
again, more Spark heavy.
We're looking to migrate
everything that we have on POS
Connect, to a new instance
of Positive Connect in Azure.
So everything will kinda
get to get brought there.
And then for our machine
learning models and everything
They'll live on
Databricks for now,
but we're looking like I said
into into other sort of more
flexible tools as well.
Thank you.
I I appreciate it. I see
Lisa's comments, and I think it was
at a fairly techie conference
I went to someone said
organizations are
always mid migration.
Yes.
Abigail. I see you had
a question in the chat.
Do you wanna jump in here?
This is like a very
specific question. So I know there's,
like, so database, obviously,
it's a notebook environment,
which, you know, some
good things, some bad things.
I know they on paper
have this, like,
v s code connector or
something like that,
but I've never met
anybody who's actually using it.
Are you using it? Can you
speak to that? Thank you.
Yeah, that's a
good question. So,
we're not using it.
I, I wish we were,
but the reasons are more
because of particularities of
the way that TD has sort
of like set up, the environment.
So Databricks
is fairly flexible,
like to have a good set of
APIs that you can kinda plug into.
So personally, I'm not
a huge fan of notebooks.
I would much prefer
using like a proper ID.
But connecting to these APIs
has some requirements in terms
of, like, path tokens
and things like that.
And then that has security
considerations where it's not
opened up for us. So we
still do have certain gaps,
which is why, I'll do a plug
for your for for pause it here.
So we're kind of interested
in this new engagement that Posit
has with Databricks of,
integrating workbench into
pub Databricks because
For us,
it kinda solves a lot of issues
because we have one single
managed environment that we
get access to. And then there,
we're, like, already
authenticated into data breaks,
and we can kind of
use VS Code and stuff.
So that's sort of like hope,
but, but yeah, we haven't used
that, that external
connector as of yet,
just because we don't
have that, like,
external connectivity set up.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank
you.
I know you covered this a
a little bit about your team,
but could you tell us a
little bit more about, like,
the data science team structure
at TD Bank?
Yes. So TD Bank,
so TD Bank has a lot of
different lines of businesses.
So you have these various
lines of businesses that each have
their own sort of
like leadership.
All of the enterprise data
and analytics is essentially under
a single leadership.
And we have different,
what we call like
practices under these leadership. So,
you know, we have
a a BI practice
We have a,
sort of like a data engineering
practice, and we have,
AIML practice. So we reside
in the AIML practice But
I would say we're
very well integrated.
So we have very close
connections with the line of
businesses, even though
organizationally,
we might be sort
of like all group,
let's say Like all the
lines of businesses,
the ML AI practitioners,
they're all grouped under one,
let's say, VP.
But we all work very
mostly with our, you know,
respective lines of businesses.
So that's roughly
the the structure.
Do you, like, get
together with, like,
community initiatives or, like,
annual conferences or
things like that too?
Yeah. For sure. So we have
we have town halls. And again,
depending on, you know,
we have like three different
town halls depending on who is
included. So we have our
own surf the AIML practice,
and then we have the
larger enterprise data and analytics family,
and then you have the different
town halls with the lines of
businesses So we do have
these like large conferences.
And I mean, you know,
the the enterprise data and
analytics community yet TD is
very large. I would say
probably we're talking about,
you know, four thousand or so.
Data practitioner.
So this includes the AIML
practitioners and everything.
So, yeah, so it's a very
large group of people. So we have,
like, subgroups need, we have
that larger group that we need.
So it includes a fairly
significant number of people.
People are a little
bit shy today, I think,
coming back in the new year.
I I noticed not as many
questions in the chat, but I
get just keep asking Marin as
many questions as I want here.
But, Greg, I see your hands
raised. Do you wanna jump in?
Yeah. It's really great. Man.
I, work for Charles Schwab,
so I feel like we're
like, cousins or something.
I don't know what
the relationship would be,
but there's a history there,
TD and Schwab. So Yeah.
One of the, challenges
that I faced.
I've been here for
six years or so,
is kind of an aversion to
open source,
packages, products,
anything that's not kind
of vetted in enterprise,
purely from, like,
a risk perspective.
I've had so many
conversations about,
you know, even well
vetted packages like,
deeplier or pandas.
And, you know,
how can we guarantee
that there's no malicious code
that's going to, you know,
come scrape and steal
all our clients.
As you mentioned,
it's it's it's a function
of being in a very highly
regulated industry.
Have you run into that and
have you, like, maybe kind of
put, put those fears
aside and, and,
kind of, can, you know,
confirm that these are
really safe and well vetted
tools and in in a
variety of industries.
Yeah. That's a that's a
good question because would say so
ten years ago when I started,
I remember. So my, you know,
just quick background.
I I did my bachelor's,
and I did my master's,
and I was like, you know,
I'm going academia.
I'm not I'm not going to the
industry, but I was like,
you know, PhD is
a big commitment.
Let me do an internship before
I kinda, like, you know,
throw myself into this, like,
you know, hell that
is doing a PhD,
and I ended up really liking
it. But I I was always more,
you know, academic actually
minded. So I started working,
and I started using r because
I kinda used it for my thesis.
And, like, very quickly,
people are like, wait,
what are you using? Like, we
use SaaS here don't use our,
like, this is open source.
Like, how do we know it's,
like, the right
outputs and everything?
And I was very lucky because
my my manager, Ashley, he told me,
like, don't listen them.
You do you. You know, you're
you're doing great work.
You do you, and we kinda
like follow down that path.
But as I would say, like,
very quickly within, like,
the next few years,
I think people started
seeing just in general, like,
different pockets.
Like, you know, I was
in a little insurance pocket,
but I'm sure the same
thing was happening in different pockets.
Very quickly,
people were trying to adopt
starting to adopt these things
because it was solving a lot
of issues that, you know,
like SaaS was, like, way
behind and, like, you know,
by the time you onboard, like,
a new tool and you have
the license agreements and
everything, like, you know,
the the project would be, like,
done and implemented. Right? So
that starts to happen,
and I think naturally we
kinda like went through this
direction where things
started getting accepted.
And I think In the meantime,
what was happening is
that there was some leadership
changes that were happening,
like enterprise data and
analytics team was being
created, and we
were very lucky.
And to this day, we're
very blessed that you know,
our leadership, they're very
forward thinking. Like, to
them, it's it's a non issue.
And even to this day, like,
for our enterprise data
and analytics team,
we're this is probably not
super common in the industry.
We're really a code first,
sort of mentality where,
you know, for example,
one of the big projects that
we have right now is creating our
own in house, machine
learning end to end library.
Right?
So this is a big
project and we're building this ourselves
and it's using, like, a
fully open source stack.
TD also acquired
an AI company. I was one of
the first bank, at least in Canada,
was one of the first banks to
to do so. And then after that,
like, other banks started
doing that as well a bit.
So I would say we've
been very lucky.
That we kind of organically
managed to adopt a lot of these
tools and we had the right
leadership in the right places
to kind of, you
know, allow that.
With that said,
it's not always without
challenge. So, for example, you
know, we still have challenges
bringing, let's say,
third party data It's not
sorry. Not third party data,
but, like, third party models
because it's like, well,
what do we know about
these models? Right?
Like, what's in these models?
So those challenges still exist.
And We have partners in
in our enterprise protect team that
actually, you know, they
proxy all the libraries.
So we don't have direct
access to the libraries.
All these libraries scanned before
they get put on our
internal repository.
So we do have these lay layers of
control that are kind of put in place.
And, you know, again,
the other layer of control that
we have is any model and stuff
that we create. Right?
We we can create models
with anything that we want,
but if we want that model
to go into production,
not like we can take any
package or anything that we want. Right?
Everything does get vetted
by a model validation team.
So that model validation
team is like, okay, like,
this library that you're using,
they look into
the documentation,
they look at all
the methodologies,
methodologies that are used,
and they end up vetting the
this can be a very long process
for certain models.
And you know, it's grueling,
and it's not the funnest thing,
but these are the controls
that they've essentially had to put
in place so that we can
do these things in a regulated,
environment. Right?
Absolutely. I appreciate
that. You you really,
painting a good picture
for a career in MRR. Right?
Yeah.
There was,
an anonymous question I wanna
make sure I didn't forget that
was over on Slido, but the question
was Do people use SaaS at TD?
I think it's finally going
away. So I think up until
there recently,
and maybe still,
but I think the the goal
for the enterprise has been to
migrate everything
out to Azure.
So I think everything is sort
of going to be moving into sort
of like this new
Databricks platform. So,
there might be some small pockets.
It it's a very big company.
So it's hard to know exactly
what's going on in every single
spot, but, very little. So I would
say. If if it's if it is,
it's some legacy
stuff that, you know,
people just don't
like attention.
Alan, I see you had
another question a little bit earlier
here. Do you wanna jump in?
Yeah. Thanks.
I'm I'm really curious about,
scaling up to the size of
team that you have now, Aaron,
where where you've got people
dedicated to this this ML AI
space and use cases there.
Was there a was there a point
where there was enough support to say, yeah,
it makes sense to dedicate
people here as opposed to you
know, sort of, like, catches
can models where, you know,
you get use cases coming in
and you try and solve them.
But those folks may be slack
for some time because up to a
certain point of time, you just
don't have those all the time.
So I'm curious what that sort
of progression was like and how
you knew when you
were like, okay. Well,
this is enough to focus on
to, like, dedicate, like, FTEs to,
as opposed to, you know,
sort of filling that
in as it as it happens.
So, just to be sure I
answer the right question,
are you referring to sort of
like AIML use cases in general
or specifically
to sort of, like,
some of the stuff that's
more like front end application and
things like that?
I guess the way I understand
your your team to be they're
focused on the AIML use cases.
And so there must be
enough of that work.
There's enough volume to
make sense to have that
specialization
action versus, like,
kind of weak pool of people.
And, yeah, and and one thing
that I can maybe, like, like,
to make a precision about my
team is that our team actually
doesn't even do that
much, specifically AIML work. In
terms of, like, the model aid
development and stuff like
that, actually doesn't
happen much in our team.
So we work with our partner.
So our team kind of
acts as like a central
spoke for projects where we
kind of coordinate a lot of
things. We get things
into production.
If there's things to build
out more engineering focus,
we do it. But the actual,
like, AIML happens in different
for different lines
of businesses.
And
the model building,
itself, that there's a huge market
for a TD. Like, we have
like between
marketing and between,
you know, insurance and all
the different lines of businesses,
the AIML practice, I would
say, has tons of work. And
I think the practice,
that is really focused
on machine learning and model
building is around hundred
and fifty people today.
And I would say, Dave,
they're fairly busy.
My team kind of focuses more on
the end to end delivery of some
of these like special
projects where,
it's not just like a model,
but it requires like a lot
of data engineering and it requires,
let's say, like, a front
end. And in our case,
like my team is roughly
eleven, twelve people.
We definitely have enough work for
us as well to to do this.
And to be honest, in
this space, we really only are
catering to insurance for now.
Once the other lines of businesses
start adopting this model as well,
I think this team will will
need to grow because One I
think that we realize
is that, you know,
building a model is one thing,
but then making sure that
the right decisions are being made
based off of these
models that's where, you know,
that's your last mile
delivery. Right? And, like,
how do you wanna present
this? Right? And, you know,
Tableau is great,
and I know a lot of industries
use use Tableau or Power BI and
things like that, but
the the part that we kind
of focus on is like, okay,
we don't wanna just
give you, data.
We wanna also capture
data from you. Right?
And that's where, you know,
how does it connect where
it gives you that flexibility of
deploying these, like,
you know, proper applications,
like, it gives you
that. So I would say,
yeah, we do have enough
use cases to kind of,
grow these things.
But if we go back, you know,
it's been a journey
of like a few years,
it started a lot
smaller. Right?
Like the team might have
been like four people
kinda doing, like, a couple of
use cases and then kind of,
like, started organically growing until
a point where, you know,
we started having to
create these specialized roles of,
like, you know, a
back end developer,
a front end developer
in these things.
Cool. Thanks. It's really,
really useful to hear.
I really appreciate you flushing
out flushing that out. Thanks.
Oh, no worries.
Thank you.
Lisa, your puppy is really
interested in this conversation
too. I think think we'll
need an introduction.
This is Finnie, and he's seven
months old. And, yeah, so far I
really love hearing about,
He was at pause at comp,
you know, from home. So yep.
Loving your conversation.
Re, I see you
asked a question in
the chat. I can if you wanna
jump in and and add some context,
feel sorry. I can read it.
I can probably read it.
So I think,
I think a lot of folks
on this call are probably working for
financial institutions or have. So I
do a lot of consulting for
financial institutions
and as, you know, obviously
we want to be implementing ML
and be, you know, building all
of these tools, but I often
am at the mercy of whatever
security and networks
kind of shenanigans that
the client might have.
So I am subjected to
their you know, security risks.
Financial data in
particular can be incredibly
sensitive. So I wanted to hear
about how you might have coordinated
or maybe
different tooling that you might
have used to get around or,
you know, work
with other teams,
to build some of the
tools that you were using.
I'm just kind of
getting started on this project.
And I'm just having a lot
of difficulty convincing
stakeholders that, you know,
this is necessary, data is
secure, etcetera.
Yeah. For sure.
So I think it's very
important to have like a good
understanding of their
framework. So I think every
larger company will probably have
their own sort of, you
know, layers of control.
Right? So there is privacy
partners on one side, like they
tell you, you know, this
is the data I wanna use.
This is what you're allowed to
do with the data and and being
able to have
those conversations, that's important.
And then you have sort of
like the frameworks that are sort of
like set by whoever is
their sort of like security team.
Right? So we call them
enterprise protect.
And typically,
it's important to understand
sort of the guardrails that
they've put in place. So
in our case, you know,
the way that it works
is that, okay. Well,
you have this zone in the zone.
You're allowed to do x y zed,
and this is sort of like
the guardless that are put in place.
And then
if there are existing
patterns that, you know,
the architecture team
has kinda put in place,
as long as you stay within
those, you're kind of okay. Now
the difficulty happens if
you have like a use case that
doesn't really fit
those patterns,
and that that's where it
becomes challenging. So, you know,
I can I can kinda speak
to that because we had those challenges
because when we were migrating
our positive connect form onto Azure,
they were like, well,
the Azure environment isn't
really made to have data coming
into it in this kind
of fashion? Right?
So that, again,
was not an easy conversation
because they had to understand
exactly what is going on.
They had to build new patterns
once we get to the point that,
you know, the
patterns were built,
all the conversations were had,
enterprise protect
gave their sign off.
Now you have this pattern that
you have that you can reuse and
kinda do whatever use case
that you need to. Right?
So I think the the key here
is to be able to, like,
abstract your use case into a
pattern that you can kind of
explain to the
partners and say, like,
this is what I need to do.
And you also have to be
kind of like, you know,
open at the end of the day that
they say, like, okay. Well,
you know, to make your data
secure, you need to do x, y,
zed, and kinda, like,
hear them out as well. So
that it's not it's not easy
and especially if I take the
consultant point of view,
I feel like that's
particularly difficult because, you know,
you you're kinda like time bound and
some of these things, I'll be honest.
We just take a lot of time
and a lot of, you know,
effort to kinda like get
things going. With that said,
the benefit that you have
on the consultant side,
I think is you know, if
you're paid by the company,
they wanna see results.
So I would say use your
business partners to kinda like, you know,
push some of those
conversations along with the
the security partners
and say, like, you know,
suddenly they understand the value
because a lot of the
conversations that we've had, you
know, I can see is, like,
if I go to them with, like,
a use case and I say, hey,
I need to do this
and it requires a new pattern,
they're gonna be like, no,
we're not gonna do this.
And essentially if I look
at it from their perspective, like,
why am I gonna bother creating
some potential risk
for this thing that you're
coming to me. Right?
So you do need to have
that support from the business side
that says, like, no,
this is important.
This is gonna enable lots of
value for us and we need your
help to tell us,
like, how to do this,
but do it within whatever,
like, risk appetite that you
have. You have that support,
it becomes a lot easier to
kind of push things along.
But you do need to
have your your business partners there
that who are, you know,
paying you to say like, hey,
I need you guys support
this because whatever you're paying
me for, I can't
do if, you know,
they don't they
don't help me out.
Thank you for such
a thoughtful answer.
Gerard. I see you have your
hand raised. Wanna jump in here.
Yeah. Sure.
So I'm I'm a prudential and
a similar scenario where
we like to hear from external
partners on how they do things
and how they solve, issues. And,
there's there's
two things that,
we use very successfully.
One is, sandboxes.
They're they're kind of the
environment that is in production.
But,
it's completely separate from
the corporate network and and
there's just nothing you
can do to break things.
And and another thing that
we, we're very good at is
making fake data that
looks a lot like our data.
And then, you know, ask
the consultant or the external
party to develop a solution
that works within that.
Knowing anyway, and I
think I think Marin,
alluded to this as well
that no matter what we
develop,
there will be an IT
organization that will take
that whole thing apart,
build it almost from scratch
when it has to go into
production anyway.
Yeah. That's a that's
a really great point.
So the sandbox is very key.
And this is actually, I think,
the concept that
at least for our IT department
was a little bit foreign,
I would say, like,
maybe going back, like,
a few years because to
them, it was like, well,
you have a dev environment,
and then you have, like,
all these you know, sit,
Pat, whatever you wanna call it,
and they have this
thing called, you know,
SDLC like the
software development life cycle.
So what they would do
is typically it's like, well,
you work with dev data,
which is non production,
like fake data, and
then you do that.
But what we eventually
convince them is that, well,
we kinda need a dev,
but we need a dev that's
with like real data, like,
essentially a sandbox because
working as a data scientist
with fake data becomes a
little bit difficult right,
when you're actually trying to
prove results on things. So so,
yeah, so the sandbox
idea of, like, you know,
it it looks like a
production, it breathes like a production,
but it's not production.
That's something that I think
is key for any data science
team to be, you know,
to be useful, right?
So that having been able to
have the freedom to do that.
Yeah. I fully agree.
That's a great point.
So as long as you can
kinda create what you need in that
environment and show the
value and everything,
And then whether it's IT that
rebuilds it or you're able to
find a different model,
that that kinda can go
a long way for sure.
And a good tip for, for
from a data perspective,
and it's not an r product.
It's, it's y data.
They have a a package that is,
really well in
creating fake data.
Oh, cool.
By looking at your own data. So
It learns from your data
and then generates fake, datasets.
So that that allows you to
have a little bit more of that
production worthy data in
a development environment to
combat the problem that
you were describing.
Yeah. That's great, actually.
Thank you. Bill, I see you had
a question a bit earlier on the
model validation team.
Do you wanna jump in?
Phil, I can I'll
ask the question.
If you wanna add more
context, feel free.
But it was interesting that
you have a model validation team,
what kind of of members and
what skill sets are on that team.
Reflected in the polls. Yeah.
Just having a chance to
play the if he is Hold on.
I'm hearing something in
the background. Not sure.
Or oh, they muted. Okay.
Here we go.
Yeah. So the model validation
team, very important team,
very popular in terms of like
anybody that is doing any
model, they interact
with them. So
That team, I would say the
the background of the
members, they're typically PhD
very highly skilled in, you
know, the academic side of
model. Like, they kind of
understand really, like, you
know, all like this.
Splitting methods, all, like,
the little detailed
methods of, you know,
how do you treat your data
and what impacts those things can
have on your model?
That's really their
their skill set.
I would say they have a
particularly difficult job as well because
first of all, like,
you know, everybody's
doing models. Right?
So you have a lot of
models come from different lines of
businesses and
You can't really look
at a model in a vacuum.
You need to understand sort of
like the business context of the models.
And if you have like a
centralized team that kinda
deals with a lot of different
lines of businesses. That means, like,
very quickly learning about
those lines of businesses and
that particular
use case. Right?
So they they also need that
skill set of, like, you know,
being able to talk
to their business,
understand what is going on,
and then also have a very deep
understanding on the technical side of the,
of the model. So so,
yeah, they're a very,
very important partner,
and they're they're really key
on getting So that's that's,
you know, one layer and then
we have a different layer that is,
more on the bice
and fairness side.
So getting the model validated is
more of a technical question of, like,
making sure that the model
is going to produce the outputs
that you expect
and and everything.
But then after that,
it's like, well,
all these variables and all these
things that we use in our models,
is it even fair to use those
in the context that you're using right? So,
and that's like a different partner
that we that we work with.
Thank you.
As we get to the last
ten minutes here. I just wanna
remind people, if there is
a question you asked a bit
earlier, anything I missed,
feel free to just raise your hand
here on Zoom so I can see
you as well.
But, Maeran, I a question
I love to ask everybody here.
Is what is one of
the most memorable pieces of career
advice that you've either
received or given throughout
your professional journey?
Yeah. That's a
good question. So,
one of the things
that, you know, so my
my manager for a
long time at, at, TD.
So, you know, I I worked
very closely with him and, like,
I wouldn't say necessary
advice that he gave me,
but it's something that
I really learned from him,
working with him and being in
meetings with him is, you know,
like, if your
vision and your goals are
set in, you know, in the
right way. Right? So and
when I say that, you know,
pessimistically, you know,
you can look at your Korean
and say like, well, you know,
I I want this job,
so I'm gonna do whatever
it takes to do that. But
I think the better way to kind
of look at your career is like,
well, what do I expect
to kind of like achieve?
Right? And what
are sort of, like,
the vision that I have for
this company. Right? And, like, think big.
And what are the steps that
you need to do to to kind of
achieve that? Like,
if you have that kind of a
mindset and you do everything,
you know, within that
kind of direction,
you will achieve great
things. And not only that,
but you'll bound you'll band together,
like, a group of people. Right?
And you have a certain
motivation because all you're
doing isn't like,
well, you know,
model is gonna
bring this benefit.
Let's just do it and get
her across the line. It's like,
okay. Well, you know, this,
for example, this call center app,
it wasn't that, you know, we
wanted to do this and, like,
solve solve the problem.
It was, like, we realized,
like, oh my god, like,
people are on the hold,
you know, during COVID for, like,
an hour and, like, we need
to help them out. Right? Like,
and and we did something
similar for for the claims
team, and it was, like,
people that were, like,
waiting for responses that
they weren't getting any,
and we realized, okay, well,
we need to kind of
like do something about this. Right?
So having back on my
side that, you know,
at the end of the day, like,
it's the clients that matter and
what's my vision and how do
I think my skill sets are
gonna, you know, help that out.
That's sort of like what
brought us our team to this
point where, you know,
what we're really doing. Right?
It's not it's not
about the application.
It's not about the the
models or anything. It's really about,
like, what's what's
the end result of this.
I love that. Thank you so much.
So do do you give your team
an opportunity to, like,
meet to talk about those big picture
things or or where do people usually?
Yeah. For sure. So we do we
try to do twice a year, what we
call an off-site. So we
kinda get together. We don't talk
about necessarily sort of
like the the specifics,
but we talk about,
sort of the division of
the team and, you know,
sort of some of the
past learnings, what went well,
what didn't go well,
what we wanna achieve, like,
sort of in the in the
in the coming year.
We also kinda combined that
with some, like, t like,
activities, just, you know,
some team building things, like,
last time we were we kinda
everybody in Montreal,
and we actually did, like,
an art, like a little,
art workshop together.
So I think that kind of
thing is important because a lot of
these sort of,
like, discussions,
about, like, vision and, like,
about the company and things
like that kinda arise from
there. And TD does this annual,
and I think they're gonna
make it more frequent, but,
what they call TD pulse,
which is they sort of get
a pulse of of everybody.
And then we get some of that
information, and sort of,
you know, things about, well,
have you in the last year
thought about getting a job somewhere else?
And we we try to talk
about those things like very openly
and try to, you know,
make things better, not just,
like, in terms of our work,
but for ourselves, right? Like,
to to be able to
produce good work,
everybody needs to be happy
at the end of the day.
That's great. Thank you.
I'm actually headed to Montreal
at the end of this month,
so I might need to ask
you for some suggestions.
Yeah.
I don't see any questions
that I missed yet.
I'm gonna double check Slido,
but I did see there's
a lot of conversation
Not necessarily questions,
but conversations about
Databricks in the chat.
And I can't read through
all the comments right now,
but I think there was
some people kind of weren't sure
really what Databricks was
when we were talking about it.
Would you be able to
give a little bit,
more insight into, like,
how your team uses
that or what it's for?
Yeah. So Databricks is
essentially like a managed
spark environment. So
essentially imagine, you know,
you wanna have, a
cluster like a spark
cluster to work with, well,
Databricks kinda lets you
do that. You press a button,
you say I want a cluster
of like this many nodes,
and then it spins that
up using whatever,
sort of cloud services. So
if it's, Azure, databricks,
it's gonna be on Azure, but
can do it on AWS anywhere else.
And then you have that
cluster source set up.
So from from the data
scientist point of view,
I would say it's
not like you know,
it's nice to be able to
have that flexibility so that you
can like request what you want
when you want. With that said,
I'm pretty sure no company
out there allows their data
scientists to spin up clusters willy
nilly because it costs a fortune.
But what it does do is that
your IT department doesn't need
to purchase a bunch of servers
and things like that on set it
up. So it it allows you to
kind of like, you know, if you have,
like, a use case, you
can say, well, like,
I have this use
case. I need, like,
a GPU cluster for this use
case. While, you know, you kind
of get your whoever needs to
approve it to say, like, okay, yeah,
we approved to to have this
kind of cluster to develop the
use case and you have it,
like, you know, within minutes. Right?
So that that's essentially data percentage
focus is really on spark runtime.
So that's I don't know.
I don't know if I did a
good enough job for a data break
sales, but, but that's sort of
like essentially what it is. Right.
Yeah. And we we didn't wanna put
the job of sales rep on on you,
but I just saw there was
a lot of conversation there in the
the chat about it. Thank
you. That's helpful.
I I wanted to maybe end
on Something you had had said
to me when we were having
our our pre call is you explain
some, like, examples your team
or use cases your team had
kinda built out with the
business and people saw it and
we're like, why aren't we
doing this already? And, like,
how was insurance doing this?
And why aren't we doing this?
And I would just love to hear
a little bit about, like,
that process internally, like,
how do you celebrate some of the
work that is being done and when people
want to do something similar,
how do they go about doing
it and learning how to do that?
Yeah. For sure. So one
of the things that,
you know, we realized is when
we do things for sort of like
our our business partners.
And at the end of the day,
they're the they're
mainly the users here.
They will go and sell
the thing for us. Like,
we have the exact on our
claims side that goes and says, like,
you know, this is the next
best thing since sliced bread,
and they go and talk to other
executives. And, you know,
that's that's where a lot
of these things come from.
So we have a lot of support
on the business side,
and that kinda comes
naturally because, you know,
they like what we do and they
like what we do because we
do pretty much exactly what
they want targeted to them.
Right?
So that kinda gets the word
out, like, very quickly.
From like a top down
kind of kind of way.
And from a bottom up kind
of way, we do have these, like,
very similar to this
event, actually,
where we come and
we do you know,
short fifteen minute
presentations of a use case,
to the very larger,
group of, like,
enterprise data and analytics
team. So like I said,
like this is upwards of
like four thousand people.
And, that starts a lot
of these conversations. They're like,
well, how do we do that?
And, for example, you know,
initially TD Insurance was,
was using Pausea Connect quite
a bit. That's where it kinda,
like, started off.
But then, you know, our wealth
partners saw this under, like, hey, like,
we have a bunch of use
cases that would be great for that.
We'd talk together and we're
like, oh, yeah. You know, and
now, you know, we have
our personal banking side.
So so things kinda start
growing organically.
But, yeah,
these sort of events are
are really useful to connect us
especially when we become like
a very big community of people.
Absolutely.
I see Gerard asked one
last question here. Any advice
for fintech conferences,
or what kinds of conferences
are you are you interested in?
Like, specific conferences?
Gerard, do you
wanna ask that here?
I wasn't reading
the whole thing.
Yeah. So so I get I get I
don't know. I got how many emails I
get that ask me to go eat
steak in New York City and sit next
to, like, a CFO or a CIO or,
new ML guru or whatever.
They're all really, really pushy.
Any conferences that you feel
are very much in the fintech
and the insurance banking
industry that are for
practitioners and not
for, I guess, posers.
Yeah. That's a good
quest because, you know,
there's the big insurtech in
Vegas, I think, that that one
is I think I I haven't
been to that one,
but I know a lot of the
partners on the business side
that I work with that's
basically the only one that
they end up going to because
that's where, you know,
you get most of the
vendors that are interesting and every
other one kind of
becomes very samey
but that is very
more that's like very, like,
sales focused, I would say.
Like, it's it's a higher level.
On the on the more practitioner
focus, I'll be honest,
I haven't seen
many, like, great,
sort of conferences.
I think, you know,
deposit confluence being
actually like a pretty good
one. And they're kinda
like far in between.
I know Anaconda does,
something very similar So
that might be,
you know,
something, but if
you know of any,
please let me know because
I've I've kinda struggled because
some of these more
sales focused one,
we do have people
that go to them,
but I always wanna send my
team to some of these more
interesting ones that
are practitioner focused.
And they're they're kind of
like few and far in between,
puzzle comping, one of the
rare ones, but, yeah, there isn't
there isn't that many.
I guess so. I would love to ask
you all then what would you like to
to see?
That would help me help
me in planning too.
Not that we're planning
any steak dinners, but
I don't know.
A lot of these conferences
seem to be focused on, like,
one or the other where,
either you have people
that are sort of, you know,
selling you know, these platforms and
things like that, or you have,
you know,
smaller meetups that are like
very technical focus in, like,
a very specific kind of area.
I think having a conference
where you kinda see, you know,
some end to end projects
where, you know,
there's the development portion
of it, but there's also,
some talks about, like, how
this thing even got deployed, right,
understanding what that flow
kinda looks like for people.
I think that that's one of
the things that would be very
interesting to see.
Cool.
Well, thank you all so
much for joining us today.
Thank you so much, Miranda,
for sharing your experience.
Kicking us off in
twenty twenty four.
Have a great rest of
the day, everybody.